the Joe Rogan experience we're saying
Jim this is the poster that's the guy
didn't know this was about a poster it's
a fair use issue with the Pepe and Alex
Jones sir and like they're arguing is
fair use and he's are humans not blah
blah blah so interesting it's not just
because it's a meme or something yeah
there's the poster yeah person behind
Alex to the left of Alex it's good
question most of these people are I know
who all of them I don't know that's like
a cigarette in their hand or a test tube
or a tampon yes what was that what is
that is that a blunt what is that
so the sharpie you're writing some on
Alex's back it's not a dude or a guy who
[ __ ] is that
yeah who is that I know everybody else
yeah whatever would you be here for days
is that diamond and silk okay I think it
was so okay oh no it must be diamond and
silca two of them Oh who's diamond and
so there are these two black ladies who
are Trump's biggest fans and they got
such a mean one and one of them always
drinks blue wine blue wine yeah
and it's like when you're so sick of his
bloosh [ __ ] they drinking literal
kool-aid
it's blue she's got a blue jay liquid
it's crazy they're green and she's a
Trump's race Asst well played a minute
maybe she's drinking kool-aid like you
can get can't get green kool-aid no I
think it's wine wine glass I think they
have blue wine now what look at the
looks at her face she's always seems sad
I don't know which ones diving for one
silk ones Vera always act really upset
the other ones just like why am I here
it's a good move if you just want
attention if you don't really support
Trump is it never the Green Line yeah
just get super outrageous may see and
they testified in front of Congress
that's why I love this timeline it's
like this is where we are they testified
in front of Congress about Facebook
censoring people
oh yeah cuz Facebook was censoring them
they said